in our series American wonders were
exploring places excuse me that make
America wonderful from majestic natural
landscapes to spectacular man-made
creations this morning
you'd better dress warmly we visit a
seasonal attraction called ice castles
Janet shamlian recently went to Colorado
to take us on a tour good morning we are
rocky mountain high 9,000 feet of
elevation and super cold perfect
conditions to take a spin around this
frozen Wonderland it's like stepping
into another world 90 minutes west of
Denver in Dillon Colorado when the Sun
Goes Down this frozen playground is the
hottest ticket in town I like it a lot
it really it's kind of like Elsa's
Kingdom and there are plenty of little
Elsa's who come to see the tunnels and
slides tall fountains and oversized
Thrones all made of ice 20 million
pounds of it gory dude it's a
photographer's dream and Kayla Everhart
thought it would make the perfect senior
photo until she took her coat off
it's like 22 degrees out here yes it is
what are you thinking
very cold the annual attraction is over
Killian effort taking about eight weeks
to build and hours each day grooming and
growing it larger by making thousands of
icicles and adding them in layers one by
one to the sculpted castle which
stretches taller each week roughly 10
million gallons of water are used to
make the ice once the castle is taken
down and then melted the water goes back
to the land I just have a feeling like
this is gonna come down on me it is not
it is not it stays where it is until we
close down for the season we have to
bring in heavy equipment
Brett Christians and moved from
California to Utah 20 years ago and
started playing with the ice outside his
home his backyard creations grew I went
home and put a sprinkler
a tripod of wood and and turn it on and
lo and behold everything got covered
with ice so the next year I made a large
wood frame turn on the water and and we
had had this little ice structure did
you start thinking wow I can turn this
into a company oh not not a duck point I
started out the next season with some
blocks of ice and snow balls and partway
through the season
I started fusing icicles in formation
and turned out to be this magic formula
a magic formula that's turned into six
ice castle locations across North
America open several months each winter
with hundreds of thousands of visitors
how has climate change impacted you know
some of your operations I'm not gonna
lie it's been challenging we have this
year's been warm in Wisconsin for
example they're having one of the
warmest year's warmest winters they've
ever had
we couldn't open until January 31st
which is like a month later than what we
usually want to open lighting built into
the castle gives it an out-of-this-world
ethereal feel and has turned the often
sold out attraction into a social media
lover's dream it's just beautiful how
they make it and I just I had to see it
are you gonna Instagram it of course I
am
[Laughter]
social media and ever existed photos
like this caught the attention of lo
Brown who came with friends to celebrate
her 30th birthday
the towering creation and epic
experience just might be the coolest
thing in Colorado how long does this rap
well you can see or slide to it until
early March here in Colorado but across
the country in the other locations it's
more weather dependent dress warm back
to you if they the coolest thing in
Colorado looks like a lot of fun I agree
I wish we had one nearby here